you know if you're having like Korean
rice and you mix the perfect bite
together that that's what it tastes like
[Music]
today we are going to make Hyderabadi
biryani it is a traditional dish it's
made in the technique of dumb books
it's just spicy and it's full of flavors
it's more of a festive dish in our
family my son here is going to cook
quickly I really really love biryani
it's like probably one of my favorite
dishes ever I've never made very ani
before I always had my mom to cook it
for me if you see all these ingredients
it looks like most Indian food is really
complicated it has a whole bunch of
spices I've cooked a bunch of my mom so
I'm pretty confident I can follow along
she is fine but she's kind of lazy
sometimes I like pampering her but now
she'll earn herself so we're gonna get
started with making the rice while the
rice is cooking we are going to do the
preparation for the gravy or the curry
effete it so we're gonna heat the water
we have rice here it's approximately a
cup full of rice and it's washed we are
going to put rice into a pot of water
make chicken biryani first we prepare
the chicken marinate it take 3 teaspoons
of the vegan butter vegan butter then we
add spices to it
we need garlic this is probably great
yes and then you see we grated the
ginger 3 TSP of garam masala 1/2 TSP
cinnamon and cumin
I would not be affected 1 teaspoon salt
I work with the spices a little bit
normally my mom will mix them all into a
little container for me he's like take 1
spoon of this spice mix and put it in my
food so I don't have to really think
about it too much so we take the
cilantro and mint and we chop it into
very fine pieces
[Music]
mix it yes for making like a PC so you
can put a little bit of water in this so
basically what we do is we take the
chicken and we stab it a little bit so
now you see we are marinating that you
can envision cooking a lot of it is love
and affection that you give to the
chicken you marinate on my phone I have
to fix the chicken what she's got to the
bathroom
[Music]
now we are going to take the salt look
like 1/4 spoon teaspoon oh let's put 2
bay leaves in it they give a nice flavor
to it and then we put for clothes on
flesh but I put around 5 of them let's
snap this into two because this is
pretty bad gonna put some cinnamon in it
so you take the cardamon out here first
and then we crush them how are you doing
that so easily if you just open it just
like you open up peanut now this is all
seasoned let's clear it put the heat on
little bit more than you know just fry
them a little bit put a little bit of
mixed nuts so it won't do the cumin is
roasting a little then we just put all
the rice and fry the rice a little bit
yeah so go ahead and saute so far so
good yeah
so while this is going to cook let's
start preparing the vegetables see
that's how good he is he knows how to do
that ends in this we usually put two
medium onions dad don't make this small
[Music]
so I came up fire yes done you've got
more practice that just means I have to
do all the cutting at home the journey
through your whole onion oh man of
course I'm waiting for him to bring a
gun help look I've taught him well so
the chicken has been marinated for an
hour let's take the marinated chicken
and we put it
all right so we will put some ghee ghee
is purified butter like love every time
you say cardamom you want to say light
cheeks but you like stop and then you're
like cardamom what is holy in English
tell me I guess like Google what if
something is in English so I can buy it
at a store being splitting the beans in
now let's put some yogurt
we're like cooking she's like I was like
job applications going and like where's
this and where's that so I'm like forced
to be here and be in tech answer my
question it's cooked on one side flip it
alright so I think our vegetables are
done now we are going to do the dumb
book topic and we have some needed milk
so the warm milk in separate is just
going to release the flavor and the
color now you put like 1 spoon of rice
in a layer we'll put some cilantro let's
spread the layer of rice then you put
your chicken on top of it I'm gonna top
it with rice so you check it like a
little bit of rice and see if it's
cooked and so we're gonna leave it about
20 minutes and it's ready to serve ok
which one is yours now see you can't
tell that means it's good this is yours
I'm sure yours looks more covered in
saffron than mine so taste like biryani
like good you had my a good job yeah
yours is better can you smooth for you
ok there we go that's a good one it just
was denied
hey eating biryani really tastes very
good when you use your ass if you've
never had biryani you should definitely
try biryani even if you can't make it at
home
well now you can maybe just have recipe
written up and then I totally
some my own maybe send her pictures of
it be like is this done he did awesome
and he's usually a very good woman
[Music]